this is just McDonnell standing in for
reviewer David wild goose memories can
be painful in Disco Elysium a
mesmerizing hilarious and at times
harrowing narrative heavy RPG
recollecting a memory can prove fatal
for an amnesiac alcoholic cop struggling
with a new murder case with elusive
details and the world's worst hangover
remembering the person he was off as a
path to redemption for the person he
might become after all memories that
don't kill you make you stronger you
really dropped the ball Harry
4.6 billion people and you failed every
single one of them
disco Elysium presents as an RPG in the
mold of boulders gate or divinity
original sin indeed it opens with a nod
to Planescape torment with a semi naked
figure lying on a cold hard slab before
slowly rising to his fate only the slab
isn't in a mortuary it's in a cheap
motel room and the figure wasn't
recently dead he's just still drunk very
very drunk it proceeds with the
traditional top-down view of the world
your party members traversing beautiful
hand-painted 2d environments pausing to
inspect objects and talk to people there
our quest to initiate experience to gain
levels to up dialogue trees to climb and
skill checks to fail yet in all kinds of
other ways somatically and mechanically
disco Elysium is very unlike other RPGs
on the one hand it's a detective game
played straight there's a meticulous
satisfaction in assuming the role of a
by-the-book cop you can grill suspects
about their movements on the night of
the murder and look for holes in their
stories about what they saw you can call
into the police station or request that
they retrieve further information about
leads you've uncovered and if there's
anything your booze frazzled brain has
forgotten you're a totally patient
partner Kim Katsuragi is always there
with a gentle reminder of the finer
details of effective police work of
course you don't have to play it
straight
disco Elysium provides a staggering
amount of options letting you choose and
roleplay the type of cop indeed the type
of person your amnesia
detective is going to remember himself
to be as such you're welcome to walk out
of your hotel room with just one shoe on
and you
able to tell the manager you're not
paying for the room nor the damage you
caused and he can frankly go screw
himself in his impeccably dry way Kim
will suggest this is not exactly
appropriate behavior but he's also not
going to stop you from reinventing
yourself as a cocky superstar cop a rude
[ __ ] cop a wretched nihilistic cop a
bungling apologetic Cup a modified
repentant cup or some tempered
combination thereof even during what
could be considered rote casebook disco
Elysium provides so much opportunity to
express yourself there's a scene in
which you and Kim are conducting an
autopsy
while Kim got his hands dirty I opted
for the paperwork this scene which
should be aggressively dry is instead
wonderfully written creative and
entertaining and threaded throughout is
the satisfying accumulation of clues the
central mystery contracting and
expanding as new information answers
questions and asks further ones but
disco Elysium is not just a commendable
detective game it is a deeply political
game that tackles issues of ideology
privilege racism and class in a
thoughtful and provocative fashion the
small seaside town you've been summoned
to is in fact the neglected
working-class district of ravashol a
city built to resolve history in the
wake of a failed communist revolution
that now sees it governed by a coalition
of foreign nations the murder you're
investigating it first seems tight when
months long labor dispute negotiations
between Union and corporate leaders are
at a stalemate striking workers have
shut down the harbour scab laborers are
picketing in the streets and road
transport in and out of town is at a
standstill
more deeply ingrained and the painful
memories of the wars that first beheaded
the rubbish our monarchy and then
quashed the revolution and the lingering
darkness of centuries old racial
resentments fuelled by the economic
anxieties of industrial change
it's a remarkable nuanced circumstance
tensions are high violence feels
inevitable and the future of revitol has
never felt more uncertain I hope you
pass out for meat you got NJ fish like
you as a piece of this nation sinking
the case you're working intersects with
the political arguments of the town you
give
openings to sympathize with or reject
various political views and your
character stats do in fact track how
much of a communist fascist ultra
liberal or moralist you are there's a
tongue-in-cheek approach here as when
you're given the option in favor of your
preferred ideology it's without
exception and utterly extreme version of
it
moderate paths don't exist there's no
room for a public option the Communists
are all about jumping straight to the
eat the rich stage indeed disco Elysium
isn't especially interested in the
typical binary ideologies explored in
most RPGs it pokes fun at extremism and
at the same time chides you for any
attempt to retreat into non-committal
centrism and it's even less interested
in trying to dodge politics instead it
wants you to focus on the dynamics of
power that structure society and the
systemic changes required to repair the
inequities of those relationships this
is a game with a specific if complex
point of view and it's not afraid to
remind you of it even when it's leaving
room for you to explore other ideas yeah
disco Elysium isn't just a formidable
game of politics and detective work
it also jettisons a bunch of standard
tropes of RPG interaction and replaces
them with new systems that delve deep
into your character's psyche there is no
combat to speak of there are certain
encounters that play out like combat
analogues except you're not choosing to
attack or defend instead you're picking
from a selection of actions and lines of
dialogue where successes or failures
depend on the skills you prioritized and
the luck of the dice
during character creation you cannot
alter the physical appearance of your
nameless cop you can however drop points
into a bunch of entertainingly unusual
and evocative skills disco Elysium skill
system is refreshingly original the
entire fascinating suite it posits
serves as a captivating exploration to
your characters inner life and echoes
his journey of self rediscovery skill
checks are being rolled all the time to
see if there's something you should know
it could be as simple as checking
whether your perception means you notice
a particular object maybe you see or
hear a word you don't recognize and your
encyclopedia skill interrupts to provide
a definition you're often able to
conduct conversations with your skills
digging for more information or telling
them to pipe down a little chorus in
your head filling the gaps and prodding
you into action these competing often
uncalled for voices add up to a
remarkably successful simulation of how
the mind works skills intrude during
conversations with other characters too
sometimes your skills offer conflicting
approaches drama might be urging you to
make a big scene but composure is
pushing back coolly arguing for
restraint much of the unpleasant things
you can say are the result of a failed
skill check it can feel weird to have
your character do something you didn't
quite intend or have your dialogue
choices restricted to three equally
offensive alternatives but there's
something pleasingly authentic in the
way things don't always go according to
plan
learning to Rives disco Elysium through
what can initially feel like a mad
jumble of competing voices is the
essential first step of attuning
yourself to the type of experience it
wants to deliver this is a game with
let's be honest an absolute ton of words
to read literally everything you do save
walking from one place to another is
conveyed and accomplished through text
and what beautiful bonkers bold words
they are disco Elysium is easily one of
the best written games I've ever played
there's a swagger and a confidence here
that's rarely seen there's a masterful
ability to transition from drama and
intrigue to absurdist comedy and pointed
political commentary in the space of a
few sentences one moment your elbow deep
in the grim details of police procedure
the next you're contemplating some
metaphysical wonder later some
hilariously grotesque joke is followed
by a spell of
and you're only moving emotional
vulnerability it might sound all over
the shop but it works because it brings
true to the fascinating multifaceted
central character you're nameless cop
can be charming offensive understandably
confused brimming with completely
unearned optimism flustered unguarded or
simply sick of everything he's had to
enjoy your skills selections and
dialogue choices nudge him in these
directions but of course the reality is
that he's always all of them the man
whose quote armpits are Lakes a scythe
of beers preceding him as he's first
introduced is the same man who licks
congealed rum off the counter of a bar
is the same man who locked in a tender
embrace with a strange woman vows to
spread peaceful communist revolution one
hug at a time is the same man who passes
the time sitting on a playground swing
whistling a tune with his detective
partner a writhing mass of contradictory
impulses and behavior as human as the
rest of us
disco Elysium is a mad sprawling
detective story where the real case
you've got to crack isn't who killed the
man strung up on a tree in the middle of
town though that in itself replete with
dozens of unexpected yet intertwined
mysteries and wild excursions into the
ridiculous is engrossing enough to
sustain the game rather it's an
investigation of ideas of the way we
think of power and privilege and of how
all of us are shaped with varying
degrees of autonomy by the society in
which we find ourselves
but now
you are all allowed
[Music]
none of this matters now none of this
matters
[Music]